three taconauts or chinese astronauts
carrying their nation's pride and the
ambition of making china the world's new
space superpower
they blasted off from the joe chuan
satellite lawn center on the edge of the
kobe desert
and in 15 minutes reached lower earth
orbit
the launch was broadcast live on state
television
a sign of china's growing confidence in
its technological might
the long march 2fy 14 carrier rocket has
accurately sent the shenzhou 14 manned
spacecraft to the designated orbit the
solar panels have stretched and operated
normally now i announce the shenzhou 14
manned spacecraft launch mission a
success
the mission is full of symbolism the
three are part of china's second
generation of astronauts
liu yang is among them she was the first
chinese woman in space and is now making
her return after 10 years
it gives me great pleasure to be able to
grow up in this era to integrate my
personal dream with the interests of the
whole country and to be entrusted to
complete the country's first manned
manual rendezvous and docking mission
the shenzo 14 spacecraft was designed
keeping temperature oxygen levels
humidity
and comfort in mind with advances in its
talking system
during previous rendezvous and docking
the orbit control strategies were all
decided and implemented by ground teams
in the current fast automated rendezvous
and docking all the orbit control
strategies are generated from
calculations by the spacecraft and then
independently implemented by the
spaceship
in 2003 china became the third country
to launch a manned spacecraft into the
earth's orbit
42 years after the former soviet union
sent the first human into space
but since 2016 under president xi
jinping missions to the moon and mars
have accelerated
president xi says turning china into a
space superpower is a critical national
priority
as space exploration becomes a new
battleground for chinese competition and
influence priyanka gupta al-jazeera
journalist leo enright covers the space
industry and he says china is pushing
hard to establish itself as a space
power
i think now the prospect of a chinese
a woman or man on the surface of the
moon uh within the next 10 years is very
real indeed and they've declared that
that is their ultimate objective the
speed with which they're building this
space station is really extraordinary
and there is nothing comparable uh in
the history of space flight and this
must cause particular concern for the
russians
because we're now at the point where the
chinese appear to be overtaking the
russians as as as a big space power and
that will cause enormous consternation
in moscow the russians made absolutely
clear and publicly that they were
looking to the chinese potentially as
their new partners in space
after the invasion of ukraine when all
their western partners pulled back
decisively now we see the chinese
playing it very very cautiously the the
idea now that china and russia would
collaborate on a moon base that is
beginning to look a little bit less
certain because china is being very very
careful how it handles russia in the
wake of the ukraine invasion